hey marvel fans i'm joined by sarah finn
how are you doing hello i'm great it's
very exciting to be here tonight how are
you
i'm i'm speechless this is incredible
what has it been like to see these young
adults that you cast
grow into
the characters that there are now
yeah it's a little emotional isn't it
to think about the journey and when we
first cast tom and zendaya and jacob i
think jacob's screen test was his first
time he ever set foot on a set in his
life and now to see how far they've come
and have the end of the trilogy here i'm
very excited to see the movie i haven't
seen it yet very excited to see it and
uh to see how the fans react well you've
done an incredible job at casting like
it's this
kudos to you what was it like bringing
back characters like willem and uh
alfred am i allowed to talk about that i
don't think so megan
i mean it was in the trailer come on
sarah i think you can yeah um it's
bonkers it's this movie is uh as big as
anything we've ever done and it's really
exciting to see how they're all going to
interact on screen together did you ever
think that would happen no
no i didn't i didn't when i first heard
the idea for the movie i thought this is
impossible but
but here we are
here we are okay
was there a moment where you're like i
don't know if we can pull this off this
is so big this is the biggest spider-man
film yet
yes luckily on my end a lot of the cast
was already in existence that i had cast
and from other wonderful casting
directors who worked on this film in
much earlier versions so in terms of
pulling it off i'm going to toss that
ball to the incredible production people
our producers amy rachel kevin feige
john watts everyone who worked so hard
to pull off a movie on this scale
[Music]
you